alright let's read this this first door
we got from Business Insider they say
some of the world's biggest Twitter
accounts are hacked here's what we do
here's what we do and don't know about
what's going on right now Elon Musk
wants to give you free Bitcoin at least
that's what his Twitter account says
don't trust him
the Tesla account is one of numerous
high profile accounts on the social
network that have been compromised as
part of a remarkable far-reaching hack
in an attempt to scam people using
digital currency Bitcoin this is
speculation and they should not be
saying it they don't know what this is
you know they can mention the tweets did
this and I think last time I checked it
was like $100,000 they had apparently
like had raised their their address as
of writing on Wednesday there there's
still a whole lot of unknowns but here's
what we do and don't know so far tons of
people and companies have been hacked
Biden Bezos Apple's official account
Bill Gates Warren Buffett Kanye West Kim
Kardashian uber Wiz Khalifa Floyd
Mayweather cash yet mr. beast xxx
temptation parody account of the tweet
of God the list goes on and on the only
common thread between the accounts
appears to be that they are all well
very famous the hackers appear to be
targeting high-profile accounts that
will spread the scam as far as possible
I love the speculation I love it they
don't know what this is yeah they sure
enough you know mics aren't about you
tweeted this the Bitcoin angle is for
dumb dumb journalists who are too stupid
to know what's happening around them
agree you take it you do one google
search as to what happened in 2013 with
the AP and you know targeting Obama is
not about getting Bitcoin not at all
no how did they get hacked that's not
clear there have been incidents in the
past in which third party social media
management apps got hacked and users of
that app were compromised I mean it
means hackers can gain access to their
accounts even though Twitter itself
wasn't breached it's not clear what's
going on in this case but the
unprecedented scale of the heck does
raise the possibility that Twitter
systems may have been breached in some
way another way this hack is unusual is
the duration of it some of the accounts
have been compromised for well over an
hour with repeated reposting the scam
message after they got deleted
presumably by Twitter in previous hacks
twitter has been able to lock down
high-profile accounts rapidly until the
account owner could regain control
it's not clear why this hasn't happened
here but I can tell you this Twitter has
completely lost control of their system
you know it seems like entirely they
can't even stop so that that's why they
froze every single blue check account
yeah well we are we are in you know this
is Wild West territory man check us out
this is what Obama tweeted he said I am
giving back to my community due to covin
all Bitcoin sent to my address below
will be sent back doubled if you send a
thousand I'll send back to only doing
this for the next 30 minutes enjoy just
sent out forty thousand dollars clearly
not real Wow
Twitter is saying nothing in a fairly
unenlightened statement via tweet
Twitter's security team confirmed there
were shenanigans happening and that it
was looking into it we are aware of a
security incident impacting accounts on
Twitter we are investigating and taking
steps to fix it we will update everyone
shortly
what's Twitter doing to stop it Twitter
appeared to have prevented all verified
accounts from tweeting an attempt to
crack down on the scam messages the
company hasn't publicly said it's doing
this but this reporter and others are
currently unable to tweet as of writing
some verified users are able to tweet
again but others cannot I still can't
some people can I think you you can't
tweet hey I am able to now you are yeah
at the last minute why if this was a
Bitcoin scam would Twitter be unable to
stop the tweets right it's not a Bitcoin
scam man that is speculative that
aspected oh this is way more
sophisticated than that
they say the scam is generally there
posting a tweet saying you know send us
a Bitcoin should I send them Bitcoin
know who's behind the attack the hack we
don't know I want to show you some
tweets here that we have pulled up so
far mike Serna much making some good
points he says if this hack were about
Bitcoin if this heck were about Bitcoin
there are thousands of ways to make more
money phishing links to make it look
like coinbase or square link to web
sites to steal personal information and
credit this ain't about some Bitcoin
crumbs he then said we were bet to a
quote we were read to inform you that
Elon Musk has passed away style press
release from the musk family along with
a short of Tesla stock would have earned
far more money than a Bitcoin scam don't
fall for the Bitcoin angle that's a
distraction this is a state-level attack
he then said the Bitcoin angle is for
our dumb dumb reporters who don't
understand that a true hack like this
wouldn't be to get a few crumbs of
crypto a country wanted to send a mess
we own your butts they succeeded in
response Twitter's stock has taken a
small hit though their stock is still
generally up but it did go down in
after-hours I want to show you this
story from April 23rd 2013 so you can
understand the severity of what this is
and why after I this this goes down and
I wrote to Adam like yo Adam I think
we're facing a major cyber attack what
was the first thing you said declared
myself warlord no no what's the first
thing you said in the news sense oh
because of the executive order yesterday
Donald Trump basically said in this
executive order mm-hm
if you are associated with China in any
way and are giving aid to them as they
repress hong kong we will take
everything yep this executive order was
i'm surprised it wasn't bigger news i I
was reading it this morning a friend of
mine sent it to me like dude you need to
read this and I was just reading it I
was I ran in here I'm like dude you have
to read this it's incredible so and then
this happened it's like it makes total
sense you know there it's a
counter-attack it basically says that if
you in any way provide aid to people
associated with the Chinese government
or in any way we're pressing the rights
of Hong Kong we will take your assets
well you know seized things you can't
travel and considering the amount of
property and resources Chinese officials
have been buying in this country and
organizations I mean this is as
far-reaching notice but let's go back in
time real quick check this out
Syrian hackers claim ap hack that tipped
stock market by one hundred and thirty
six billion dollars is it terrorism look
at this you can see on the screen this
blip right there where the whole market
just dropped and bounced back up what
you are seeing in that is a
sophisticated cyberattack but not only
that it was the destruction of the lives
of so many innocent people yeah who
didn't know it was about to happen and
all of a sudden these retirement
accounts these Nate J traders had these
automated sell offs occur because the
price dropped so rapidly and then other
people who had automatic you know buy
the stock terminology is called but
automatically wanted to buy gained all
those assets in the price skyrocketed
back up you lost all your assets like
that
they say at 1:07 p.m. on Tuesday this is
April
23rd 2013 when the official Twitter
account for The Associated Press and a
tweet - it's nearly 2 million followers
that warned I'm not gonna read what they
said but they basically said that a
catastrophic event had occurred and
Obama was hurt some of the people who
momentarily panicked were apparently on
or near the trading floor of the New
York Stock Exchange at 108 the Dow began
a perilous but short-lived nosedive it
dropped about 150 points from for a 14-6
97 to 14 5 for 8 before stabilizing at
1:10 p.m. when news the tweet had been
erroneous began to spread by 113 the
level had returned to 14 690 during
those 3 minutes
the fake tweet erased 136 billion
dollars in equity market value just two
and a half weeks ago Bloomberg LP
announced that it would begin adding a
small number of Twitter accounts to its
financial information terminals which
are ubiquitous in Wall Street's
financial offices the idea ironically
enough was to combat misinformation
spread on Twitter in August false
information spread on Twitter suggesting
that Syrian President Bashar al-assad
had been killed
sending crude oil prices spiking the
market appears to have recovered from
the AP Twitter hack which was both
juvenile and easily fixed the AP got
word out quickly to the tweet was the
result of hack and twitter shut down the
compromised account now you can see the
true power the absolutely true power and
that was a Twitter and that was a v-tach
one account one one tweet one tweet one
tweet had that effect and Twitter was
able to go in and go delete yeah they
can't do it now Twitter is panicking a
dumpster fire does not describe the
level of chaos that isn't that is inside
of Twitter right now no they are
probably sweating bullets that's
probably an understatement
if they're unable to remove these
accounts the the degree to which they've
been compromised is incredible and if
they can do 136 billion dollars in
damage with one tweet and then Jack was
able to reverse it imagine how much
damage they could do to our economy with
a tweet from former President Obama
current presidential candidate
Democratic frontrunner Joe Biden yeah
Elon Musk Bezos yeah what do you think
would happen if say Joe Biden tweeted
out something you know we're we're
shocked too
inform you the president has suffered a
massive cardiac arrest or something like
that and then Barack Obama tweets out
you know we're really sorry to hear this
we've had our differences but the
president then you hear all of a sudden
Elon Musk's we do the same thing
something similar they're all unique
tweets right everybody would be
screaming yeah they leave it the markets
would panic people would be running out
their door running every store to buy
everything off the shelves it would be
absolute chaos riots would break out yep
because you'd see all of these different
high-profile accounts basically
confirming some catastrophic event and
Twitter can't take it down this was a
shot across the bow man yeah this was
them saying we own you yep back off yeah
because of that executive order is
basically Trump going I'm sick of it I'm
done I'm done with it
we're good word now doing something
about it and then this happens the very
next day no no no it's not a coincidence
well if you if you read the wordings
yeah well I've got a pulled up but first
I want to show you this from Chris Lu he
is the former Obama White House cabinet
secretary and he said as the Twitter
accounts of prominent people slash
companies are hacked
let's take note of how troubling it is
for a president to announce policy
decisions including military threats on
a platform susceptible to intrusions we
are one hack away from a major
international incident true it already
happened in 2030 it already happened
those stocks didn't just impact America
it impacted everyone around the world I
mean there are foreign traders there
that you know they're those Martin the
markets are connected to each other in
various ways that that damage probably
rippled out across the world you know so
he's technically right but we've already
been there well and then we got the DNC
calling for every single person and
they're in their employ to dilly
tick-tock the hole the hole delete
tick-tock thing and it's like okay well
it's becoming very very obvious tick
tock is a phishing app gonna send your
data to China exactly now they deny that
of course they of course we're not doing
that we're not owned by China but they
have ties to you know some of the
highest ranking officials in the company
right I think it's called by dance yeah
I don't know the full details thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune into this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you